hi i'm scott phillips game director on
Assassin's Creed Odyssey today I'm
excited to give you a sneak peek at
three years of hard work from the
Ubisoft Quebec team as we've continued
to transform Assassin's Creed into a
full-blown RPG with choice at the center
of everything in the game in Assassin's
Creed Odyssey you will play a mercenary
who embarks on an epic Odyssey to
reunite their family and confront the
ones who tore it apart during that
adventure you will sail the agencies and
explore the lands of ancient Greece
circa 5th century BCE and for the first
time ever you will choose to play as
either a male or female hero
Alexios or cassandra both heroes share
the same fully realized story and
amazing gameplay today we're going to
play as Cassandra as she arrives at the
beautiful Greek island of Mykonos
ah
Mykonos island built from the corpses of
giants slain by the legendary in Atlas
Brittany the note again eagle bearing
mistress that's you we are a small but
fierce group of rebels who pay you
handsomely to help us overthrow our
Athenian oppressors a warrior named Theo
please fights with them none who faced
him survive please miss deus our people
are dying
signed Kira
[Music]
what did your informant are you world
has already spread of you sinking those
ships there's a price on your head oh
that didn't take long
there's also world of Spartans landing
on Mykonos so I'm here to find Kira who
wants me to kill their place in Athenian
Ally who's at war with Sparta and don't
forget the bounty business as usual them
gods protect you Cassandra
thanks for nervous but they'll be too
busy protecting the Elise from me Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you're chasing your own gems
[Music]
you watch my hips come and take it
you
[Music]
you really should have left me alone
[Music]
but novice was right the spartans have
made themselves right at home I'm
looking for Kyra what do you want with
her ha the mercenary who bears the eagle
of Zeus you got my message
it said something about paying me
handsomely mercenaries Athenians have
enslaved their people for too long
help us free Mykonos from their grasp
and you'll have more drag me than you
can carry
[Music]
I'm here to kill vo Cleese not go to war
which is why I sent word of a rebellion
to you and Sparta my men are ferocious
in a ground assault but we're
outnumbered India Cleese fights with the
fury of Ares join us in battle if you're
half the warrior Kira says you are we'll
grind these Athenians into dust
all right Spartan I'll fight with you
but the kiss is mine
to battle them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how can a child save us all if he's
sentenced to die
tell me Nicholas tell me before you let
our son go where we begin does not
define who we will become
[Music]
before you buy see a bar built by
friendship and family love
[Applause]
you are sent by the gods to protect this
world
[Music]
blade of yumminess act like it
as you write your obviously across
and this
of Greece
[Music]
you
[Music]
you